we've gone through transs she's not for
the transition she's for the medicine
pro hormones in some cases then I bring
in korin is that something that we
should allow parents to do if the kid
wants to take their lives because it's
hard she's then saying no then it goes
down to some people from truns are
having true mental issues that they're
going through which is the next thing
you said fair I'm with it but I want to
know why the other day I have this guy
at the uh uh Rob who what's what's our
friend's name that we talked to the
plumber legendary plumber Eric Hecker
who's a a a rathon whistleblower I can't
wait for this to come out I'm telling
you you will be entertained the entire
time but he said something very
interesting he said you know what is
mental illness and how long has mental
illness been around he says you realize
if you have heart issues we can show you
have heart issues yeah you can you got a
murmur or you got blood cloth high blood
pressure or you got high blood pressure
there is data to say that